foreign
giving a rare Glimpse at daughter Nala
love love love the actress shared a few
snaps in honor of her eldest child whom
she shares with ex Gabriel Aubry turning
15. Oh yay I love it the first a
throwback with the mother-daughter Duo
cuddling and laughing the next a shot of
young Nala lounging by the water and the
third Nala as a teen looking stylish
while posing on a couch I wish they
would just stay little forever yeah
Hallie wishes but they grow up mama bear
mode
in the caption Holly asked man to send
Nala some birthday love and gushes one
of the greatest gifts the universe has
given me is my daughter Nala she is the
son that never Fades and the Moon that
never wanes there's nothing I wouldn't
do from my children Hallie's also Mom to
nine-year-old Maceo with ex Olivier
Martinez this is a really I think going
to be a really defining time in my life
for me to step into another another
light into another area that I'm
completely passionate about and I'm so
ready for it the Oscar winner keeps her
kids mostly out of the spotlight but she
had no problem telling E.T how they
inspired her decision to step behind the
camera having my children now is the
reason I'm even directing because I have
to keep going I have to keep discovering
more facets of who I am I have to keep
trying to make them proud I have to keep
modeling for them someone who's alive
and very involved in their career and as
a woman and as a black woman I need to
model for them what that looks like so
they've changed they've changed my game
since the minute they got here
[Music]
thank you